[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live more incognito
here
iron little podcast lords of gaming.net
and who is this far and gentlemen we
have in the realm today at play nyc
my name is andrew thomas of uh andrew
simon thomas
nice yeah what does andrew simon thomas
do what what
games does he develop um andrew simon
thomas develops whatever
games he's thinking of at the moment
so let's talk about this game yeah yeah
so this is called roll control
[Music]
i started working on it about three
years ago
uh actually through um through play
crafting i was taking up a play crafting
class
learning how to use unity and i really
wanted to make a game that you could
play by using your body
and so i figured out uh that
if you put a uh cell phone
on a balance board okay you could use
the accelerometer data
um you know because it always knows what
direction you're going and then
you just stick it on it's connecting
over wi-fi
and then it's running with the game in
real time wow that's pretty cool
one thing i want to start with is the
fact that like you went through play
crafting
learning unity getting like tell me
about that process because a lot of
people want to get into game dev
yeah and they just really don't
understand what play craft and provide
what it does
and how again how it helps someone like
you create a game with this unique
concept it's like a general like that's
pretty cool yeah
yeah so i um i have an art background i
studied sculpture in college
and i really wanted to do digital
stuff because that seemed like you know
that's where the
industries and everything were going so
i started learning 3d modeling
and was having a really fun time with
that uh and i also always wanted to make
video games
um and you know i tried them multiple
times and it's just
the you know the idea of learning a
coding language was really intimidating
um it's difficult and after a couple of
failed attempts i decided to
take a a class with play crafting i
actually won some money from my
company for um personal development uh
so i
you know talked to them i got involved
with the class the teachers were great
it was just really helpful to be with a
group of other students who were kind of
at
the same place we're all trying to learn
together everyone was super nice
uh we had some really good teachers john
john corn is over there yeah
let's give john a shout out let's give
you a shout out
that's good uh and so you know those
those guys were great like they were
just really supportive
um and really like all i needed was
someone
i could just go and ask dumb questions
too you know and just be like this
doesn't make sense explain it to me
um and so yeah after that you know i i
got to the point where i can start
picking things up a little bit on my own
i can't say that i'm a good programmer
at all
um here sir you are here
i'm a good googler that's what i can say
so besides googling
so okay so now we got ball patrol's out
like tell us
he's having a ball he's having a ball
with him he's had a great time
it's really fun in a active and
uh you just want you're just like right
now i'm like
i think you need to get back on it yeah
you got to get back up he got the
addiction baby he got the fever
so tell us okay i've got the stage
design level design above all control
tell us the
objective so uh there's a couple
different modes in real control this is
the infinite mode
so if you want to just play see how far
you can get your the goal is to collect
as many coins as you can um and every
time you
get to a new stage the level will change
and it will get more difficult
so it's all randomly generated and it's
meant to just have you keep going
there's some other modes so uh there's
also a kind of an adventure mode
with some pre-made levels and there is a
level editor so anyone could
build their own stage uh and
i'll see you around yeah we'll catch up
uh
anyone could build their own stage um
and then share them too so they're oh
you can share the statements you can
they're really just text files so you
can just copy that in and share it and
so
my goal with all this was to kind of
make something that could be
um used by anyone with you know whatever
you have
uh at home and just like make it you
know really lightweight and easy to to
pick up and play it's really cool so as
far as like again you start procedural
generation right on different stages
now as far as like they're a failed
mechanic it's like
like was the time based like as far as
like do you lose in one control like
yeah so you lose by falling off the
stage
um they're in this mode there is a time
mechanic because the blocks are falling
behind you so that you don't
as you can see yeah just stay there um
but yeah really there's
the only way that you lose is something
knocks you off the stage or are you
following me
yeah that's awesome and then we got this
other game
yeah we got this other game so
uh you know the pandemic happened i
i love showing role control at shows and
having people be able to
physically play it and um when i
realized i couldn't do that and i didn't
know for how long
i decided to put the game out on steam
so it's available right there actually
and then i just was like i have to make
a new game this was my first game
i learned a lot i knew i made a lot of
mistakes um and i wanted to make
something different
um what did you learn coming from bowl
control
now to slay like what did you learn what
some of the key things you learn
key things i think it's in terms of just
like programming
um you know i was using like very
basic techniques i was using like i
don't know like all
if then kind of like boolean statements
and stuff like that like i and i
so this is like a little bit more
advanced but not
not much uh improvement yeah
yeah exactly um and i mean at the time i
was playing
you know through the pandemic i've been
playing a lot of call of duty like just
a lot of
old school shooters
and a game called devil daggers that i
was really into and i just thought
that was like the perfect indie game
it's just like really small and
contained and intense
um and that kind of became the model for
what i wanted to make myself and that's
the inspiration and that's yeah
yep that's chile so tell us now about
like what's the basic premise tell us
what's going on here
yeah so you are a druid
let's get a little come on in um you
have uh
for some reason gone down into the abyss
um
and you're fighting against this giant
monster
that has consumed everything in in hell
basically
uh and so it kind of like builds off of
the story of hercules
uh fighting the hydra okay um so in
hercules uh
what do you call these tasks or you
can't remember it yeah
one of the one of the monsters hercules
killed was a creature called the hydra
okay um and it is a monster that every
time you cut off one of its heads
it would sprout two more heads and so
he realized that he had to cut them all
off as quickly as he could
and i think he like carterized the
wounds or something so that they
wouldn't sprout and then
the last head he sealed under a rock
under the ground
and the idea in here is that it didn't
die it just went
in to hades and it
consumed everything and now you're we've
got to deal with it so now you've got to
deal with this so now you're a new hero
um and you have this uh magic stick
called the chalele right
i was about to ask you what the hell is
that
from irish mythology there's a um a club
that can
kill or it can give life and so the idea
here is that you're
instead of just killing the hydras
you're turning them into
some new form of life that are the the
trees that you use in the stage
um so as the the monsters spawn up
through the ground they destroy the
stage
and you have less and less ground to
work with oh so you're losing real
estate
okay got it kind of like your health but
the trees when you plant them they will
you know spread grass and that protects
that spot and so you can use the
i'm calling it solar spirit you can use
the the power from the trees
to fight the hydras and then you get
more trees to kind of protect
what you have left as it goes so like
are we doing like traditional
level design it will be levels in
absolutely or is it
we're dealing with the particular that
particular environment whether it be
the giving the trees or transforming
enemies and stuff of that nature yeah
you're
you're really just like it starts on a
grid that's just completely flat and
then
as the hydras um like the waves of them
come in
they spawn randomly so the level is
always
kind of dynamically changing as you are
playing and that's actually that's a
good point that's something i learned
from this
too i like uh random generation it's
easier as a
level designer um and it's fun because
it's different every single time nice
nice you get that uniqueness
it's not the same exact experience and
again i wish lately
is this out now where can we find this
so this is available as a demo on steam
right now
okay um and yeah the first 10 waves
you can play right now that's actually
what we're doing here uh and it's going
to be out
uh sometime in the fall okay cool
awesome and i wanted to ask you this
both of these are
on steam there's this uh little device
that's out yeah a lot of people are
excited about as a
linux background and maybe you know it
would be kind of cool to pay
chile or maybe from ball control on that
steam deck
does anything you can tell us about that
sir i i reserved mine
uh so that's full
that was smooth i like that i like that
you deserve joe that's good you know as
a developer
i would assume it'll be something you'd
be interested in possibly
yeah i'm i'm pretty excited for it um
you know i'm excited to learn more about
how it works i need to
obviously like figure out you know
rethink some of the controls and things
like that um
yeah i think it's really cool yeah it's
a really cool device and again
a lot of people are excited about it it
would be cool to actually get these
games over on steam
and hopefully with dev kits make that
transition easy for you guys right to
get it on the platform
because again i think it'll be really
cool to play all these games on the goal
and stuff like that but look we'll be
looking out for it man it was good to
see you
number one we remembered since pax 2020
when we saw bull patrol in a bar people
were playing it as you saw the gentleman
earlier having a good time
almost losing their balance when you're
gonna say that it was it was a fantastic
time man it was awesome to see you
and again for people to learn more about
you or learn more about both games
where can they go where can they find
the information uh my website is andrew
simontomas.com
um and then uh emotional meteor as uh
a thomatron um
yeah no doubt no doubt you're already
here for an and above all control
is there any
and last question player yc studio based
out of new york
or where are you guys based out of i'm
based out of uh queens
oh killer queen's in the building yeah
gotta be in that family we're gonna talk
about it
but anyway look you heard it here first
andrew's got the games out ball control
very unique
we got the you know little gyro thing
going on we've got chile we're learning
about
irish mythology which is pretty cool and
uh yo go check those things out man
we're out of here
[Music]
you